This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's a daytime talk show that airs on CBS called The Talk. It's kind of like the view, if you've ever seen that. Five female hosts sitting around a table discussing current events. And when it returned for its fourth season premiere in 2013, they came up with this stunt called Secrets Week. Over the course of the week, each of the five co-hosts took turns revealing one of their deepest, darkest, juiciest secrets.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）有一档日间脱口秀节目叫《谈话》（The Talk）。如果你看过《观点》（The View）的话，它和那档节目有点像。五位女主持人围坐在一张桌子旁讨论时事。2013年，当该节目第四季首播时，她们策划了一个名为“秘密周”的噱头。在那一周里，五位联合主持人轮流揭露了自己内心深处最黑暗、最劲爆的秘密。
Because who doesn't love a good secret? That's our newest producer, Vivian Lee. For example, we learned that week that Sharon Osborne had a fling with Jay Leno. Uhhh, that's a state secret. But more interesting was a secret from one of the other co-hosts, Julie Chen. My secret dates back to when I was 25 years old and I was working as a local news reporter in Dayton, Ohio. Now, I want to see.
因为谁不喜欢听好玩的秘密呢？这是我们最新的制作人薇薇安·李。例如，我们在那一周了解到，莎朗·奥斯本曾与杰·雷诺有过一段风流韵事。呃，那可是国家机密。但更有趣的是另一位联合主持人朱莉·陈的秘密。我的秘密要追溯到我25岁的时候，当时我在俄亥俄州代顿市担任地方新闻记者。现在，我想看看。
The way Chen tells it, she'd been paying her dues as a reporter, but what she really dreamed about was becoming an anchor. It's cold out in the field. I wanted to try and get a seat on the anchor desk. But when she approached your news director about the possibility, he gave her some feedback. And he said, because of your heritage, because of your Asian eyes, sometimes I've noticed when you're on camera and you're interviewing someone You look disinterested you look bored because your eyes are Are so heavy. They're so small Uhhh, I hate people
据陈述，她当时作为一名记者一直在努力工作，但她真正梦想的是成为一名主播。在现场采访很冷。我想尝试争取主播台上的一个位置。但当她向新闻总监询问这种可能性时，他给了她一些反馈。他说，因为你的血统，因为你的亚洲眼睛，我有时注意到当你在镜头前采访别人时，你看上去心不在焉，你看上去很无聊，因为你的眼睛太沉重了。它们太小了。呃，我讨厌这种人。
Yeah But Chen who's Chinese American found herself wondering if Maybe he had a point and reached out to a prominent talent agent for some career advice. And he actually took it a step further. He said, I cannot represent you unless you get plastic surgery to make your eyes look bigger. And then Chen admits to the audience that she did it. She got the surgery, a procedure called blepharoplasty. For people who are not of east or southeast Asian descent, blepharoplasty is usually done to lift looser sagging skin around the upper eyelids caused by aging. Just Google Kenny Rogers
是的。但身为华裔美国人的陈开始怀疑他是否说得有道理，于是向一位著名的经纪人寻求职业建议。而他实际上更进一步。他说，除非你去整容让眼睛变大，否则我无法代理你。随后，陈向观众承认她确实做了。她做了手术，一种叫做眼睑成形术的手术。对于非东亚或东南亚血统的人来说，眼睑成形术通常是为了提拉因衰老而松弛的上眼睑皮肤。去谷歌搜一下肯尼·罗杰斯就知道了。
before and after 2003. But for a lot of people of Asian descent, this surgery is more commonly referred to as double eyelid surgery. About half of Asians, myself included, are born with what's called a monolid or a single eyelid, which means that there's no visible crease on the eyelid skin above the lash line. This is what Julie Chen had before. The double eyelid surgery adds a crease, so instead of the skin of the upper lid running smoothly from the bottom of the eyebrow, straight down to the eyelashes, there's now a small, indented fold in the skin, just a few millimeters wide that runs in a horizontal crescent above the lash line. This crease suddenly
2003年前后的对比照。但对于许多亚裔来说，这种手术更常被称为双眼皮手术。大约一半的亚洲人，包括我在内，天生就是所谓的单眼皮，这意味着睫毛线上方的眼睑皮肤上没有可见的褶皱。这就是朱莉·陈以前的样子。双眼皮手术增加了一个褶皱，所以上眼睑的皮肤不再是从眉毛底部平滑地直通睫毛，而是在皮肤上出现了一个几毫米宽的凹陷褶皱，在睫毛线上方形成一道水平的月牙。这个褶皱突然
changes the eye shape in a way that makes the eye itself appear slightly larger. The simplest method doesn't even involve any cuts, just a few stitches along the eyelid to create the crease. Chen got the surgery in the mid-90s, but she kept it hidden from the public up until 2013. In that day, when she tells the audience about it, it was surprising to me to hear her sounding so excited. I want to show you, I want to really demonstrate like what my news headshot looked like before I had this plastic surgery done. I mean, if you look at the after, that the eyes are bigger, I look more alert.
改变了眼睛的形状，使眼睛本身看起来稍微大了一些。最简单的方法甚至不需要任何切口，只需在眼睑上缝几针来制造褶皱。陈在90年代中期做了手术，但直到2013年才向公众公开。在那一天，当她向观众讲述这件事时，听到她语气中流露出的兴奋，我感到很惊讶。我想给你们看，我想真正演示一下我做整容手术前的新闻头像是什么样子的。我的意思是，如果你看术后的照片，眼睛变大了，我看起来更机灵了。
Fabulous. More expressive. More expressive. And listening to that response, Sharon Osborne saying, Fabulous. It's sort of disturbing to me. Double eyelid surgery is one of the most popular procedures for Asian Americans.
太棒了。更具表现力。更具表现力。听到这个回应，听到莎朗·奥斯本说“太棒了”，我感到有些不安。双眼皮手术是亚裔美国人最受欢迎的手术之一。
And hearing such a positive reaction, it really is no wonder why. The hopes of looking fabulous are more expressive for the same reasons why people in my own family have had the procedure done themselves. And this ethnically specific surgery may have its roots in Asia, but it wasn't Asian doctors who popularized it. It was popularized by a white guy from the US who thought he was doing Asian people a
听到如此积极的反应，也就难怪为什么了。希望看起来“太棒了”、“更具表现力”，这和我家里人自己做这个手术的原因是一样的。这种具有种族特征的手术可能起源于亚洲，但推广它的并不是亚洲医生。它是由一个美国白人推广的，他认为自己是在帮亚洲人一个
favor by helping them look less Asian. But before we get to him, the origin of double eyelid surgery itself dates back much further to 19th century Japan. Beauty standards will always vary from culture to culture and even within the same culture over time. Double eyelids are seen as a beauty preference for a lot of Asians and Asian Americans today, but that wasn't always the case. There's actually little to no record of double eyelids as an aesthetic preference until something called the Meiji Restoration.
忙，帮助他们看起来不那么像亚洲人。但在我们谈到他之前，双眼皮手术本身的起源可以追溯到更早的19世纪日本。审美标准在不同文化中总是不同的，甚至在同一文化中也会随时间而变。双眼皮在今天的许多亚洲人和亚裔美国人眼中被视为一种审美偏好，但这并非一贯如此。事实上，直到所谓的“明治维新”之前，几乎没有关于双眼皮作为审美偏好的记录。
Before the 1860s, Japan practiced a policy of isolationism and limited their contact with other nations. But during the Meiji Restoration, which took place from the 1860s through the early 1900s, Japan opened up. It began incorporating a European-style banking system, new kinds of scientific technology and western-style clothing. It was also around this time that the first double eyelid surgery was performed by a Japanese surgeon.
19世纪60年代之前，日本实行孤立主义政策，限制与其他国家的接触。但在19世纪60年代到20世纪初的明治维新期间，日本开放了。它开始引入欧洲式的银行体系、新型科学技术和西式服装。也正是在这个时候，第一例双眼皮手术由一位日本外科医生实施。
It's easy to find like woodcut images or pictures of, say, 1880s, 1890s of a limited number of Japanese female patients having eye changes. This is John Demoya, a professor of medical history at Seoul National University. He says that as Japan's contact with Western nations increased, so did an appreciation for double eyelids over monolids. And this seems to be the case
很容易找到1880年代、1890年代的木版画或图片，显示少数日本女性患者接受了眼部改变。这是首尔国立大学医学史教授约翰·德莫亚。他说，随着日本与西方国家接触的增加，对双眼皮胜过单眼皮的欣赏也随之增加。这种情况似乎也发生在
with a lot of Asian countries. Particularly places in Asia, where there was a heavy contact either with the British Empire or with the broader, you know, Jews the word American Empire. These tend to be places where blood for a plastic has tended to pop up. It's these moments where Asian countries begin developing relationships with Western empires. That double eyelid surgery becomes more visible. Made you Japan, definitely South Vietnam.
许多亚洲国家。特别是在亚洲那些与大英帝国或更广泛的——你知道的，美国帝国——有密切接触的地方。这些地方往往是眼睑成形术出现的地方。正是在这些亚洲国家开始与西方帝国建立关系的时刻，双眼皮手术变得更加显眼。明治时期的日本，绝对还有南越。
There was lots of plastic surgery going on prior to enduring the Vietnam War and post-Creature War. But while Blufferoplasty may have already existed in Asia here and there, it didn't really take off in popularity until the Korean War. In Korea, United Nations troops push on and the clashes advance against the communists. The Korean War is technically still ongoing, but the actual fighting between northern and southern forces lasted from 1950 to 1953.
在越南战争之前、期间和之后，都有大量的整容手术。但虽然眼睑成形术可能已经在亚洲零星存在，但直到朝鲜战争它才真正流行起来。在朝鲜，联合国军队推进并对抗共产主义者。朝鲜战争在技术上仍在进行，但南北双方的实际战斗从1950年持续到1953年。
By the time the armistice was signed, dividing the peninsula into north and south Korea, the impact of the war had left South Korea pretty reliant on help from western nations. What happened, obviously, created a certain path dependency in the sense that much of the aid was coming from Western countries. This came in the form of food, construction, and importantly medical aid, which is how an American doctor named David Ralph Malard ended up in South Korea. He's a military doctor. He doesn't arrive until Korea until the war is winding down
当停战协定签署，将半岛划分为南北朝鲜时，战争的影响使韩国相当依赖西方国家的援助。发生的事情显然产生了一种路径依赖，因为大部分援助来自西方国家。这以食品、建筑和重要的医疗援助的形式出现，这就是为什么一位名叫大卫·拉尔夫·米拉德的美国医生最终来到了韩国。他是一名军医。直到战争接近尾声时，他才抵达韩国
or just after. Malar had graduated from both Harvard and Yale, then served in the Navy before settling on reconstructive surgery as a specialization. He studied under Harold Gilley's, the father of modern plastic surgery, who was known for repairing the bodies and faces of World War I and World War II soldiers named in battle. I don't know if the word I don't want to say normalcy, but he wants to restore some sense of a face that actually resembles a human face.
或者就在那之后。米拉德毕业于哈佛和耶鲁，随后在海军服役，之后选择重建外科作为专业。他师从现代整形外科之父哈罗德·吉利斯，后者以修复一战和二战中在战斗中受伤的士兵的身体和面部而闻名。我不知道该不该用“正常”这个词，但他想恢复某种看起来确实像人脸的面孔。
Malard was stationed in Seoul in 1954, where he served as chief plastic surgeon for the United States Marine Corps. It was his job to provide reconstructive medical assistance to those suffering from disfigurement caused by war, burns, or simply by lack of medical access. Malard was a fan of old West films. He'd grown up writing horses and learning to tie knots and spinning ropes, and idealizing manly western stars like Ken Maynard and Buck Jones.
米拉德于1954年驻扎在首尔，担任美国海军陆战队的首席整形外科医生。他的工作是为那些因战争、烧伤或仅仅因为缺乏医疗条件而导致毁容的人提供重建医疗援助。米拉德是老西部片的影迷。他从小骑马、学习打结、挥舞绳索，并崇拜像肯·梅纳德和巴克·琼斯这样充满男子气概的西部明星。
He ended up bringing this kind of cowboy- good guy savior mentality to his work in some strange and very literal ways. He first became well known for doing cleft palate surgeries on children. In his autobiography, which he titled Saving Faces, he tells the story of his first cleft palate patient in South Korea. Malard had been looking for someone to test a new method on, but he was having a hard time finding a willing subject. When he couldn't find a volunteer, he decided to rustle up one himself.
他最终以一种奇怪且非常字面的方式将这种牛仔式的“好人救世主”心态带到了他的工作中。他最初因给儿童做腭裂手术而闻名。在他题为《拯救面孔》的自传中，他讲述了他在韩国的第一位腭裂患者的故事。米拉德一直在寻找可以测试新方法的人，但他很难找到愿意接受手术的对象。当他找不到志愿者时，他决定自己去“套”一个。
This is before institutional review board exists. He's largely self-authorized. Milard bragged that he spotted a 10-year-old South Korean boy with a cleft lip, and ran back to grab a lasso that he kept in his footlocker. Yes, you heard that correctly. Malar brought a lasso over 6,000 miles to South Korea. I do not like where this is heading. He lassoed the 10-year-old and performed the surgery on him. And in case you were wondering, no, he did not have parental permission to do this. Backing away historically, probably today,
这是在机构审查委员会存在之前。他基本上是自我授权的。米拉德吹嘘说，他发现了一个患有唇裂的10岁韩国男孩，于是跑回去拿了他放在储物箱里的套索。是的，你没听错。米拉德把套索带到了6000英里外的韩国。我不喜欢事情发展的方向。他用套索套住了那个10岁男孩并为他做了手术。如果你在想，是的，他没有得到家长的许可。从历史角度看，即使在今天，
he could not do many of the things that he did, where someone else looking in and actually reviewing his work from professional standpoint. As crude and horrifying as Mlard's methods could be, his work in cleft palate repair did get him respect in the field of reconstructive surgery. But he would soon become famous, or maybe infamous, for another procedure entirely. Bluffer a Plasty. Or with the double eyelid surgery. Malard was the first documented surgeon to perform this procedure in South Korea. On a translator, he covered this in an essay that he wrote about his time overseas called
他也无法做他所做的许多事情，因为会有其他人从专业角度审视他的工作。尽管米拉德的方法可能粗糙且令人恐惧，但他在腭裂修复方面的工作确实使他在重建外科领域赢得了尊重。但他很快就会因另一项完全不同的手术而变得出名，或者说臭名昭著。眼睑成形术。也就是双眼皮手术。米拉德是第一位有记录在韩国实施该手术的外科医生。在一位翻译身上，他在一篇关于他海外经历的文章中提到了这一点，文章名为
Oriental Paragrenations, meaning Oriental Journeys. He depicts a Korean male translator who is coming to him because he wants to look different than he looks." Malard recounts, quote, A slantide Korean interpreter, speaking excellent English, came in requesting to be made into a round eye. Unquote. The interpreter then tells Malard that his translation work relies on his relationships
《东方游记》（Oriental Peregrinations）。他描述了一位韩国男性翻译，他来找他是因为“他想看起来与众不同”。米拉德写道，引用：“一位说英语极好的斜眼韩国翻译，请求被改造成圆眼。”引用结束。随后，这位翻译告诉米拉德，他的翻译工作依赖于他与美国人的关系。
with Americans. So Malard writes, quote, He felt that because of the squint in his slant eyes, Americans could not tell what he was thinking, and consequently, did not trust him. As this was partly true, I consented, unquote. Which sounds familiar. It's basically the same feedback that Julie Chan got 40 years later, that people couldn't read her expressions and audiences wouldn't relate to her.
所以米拉德写道，引用：“他觉得因为他的斜眼，美国人看不出他在想什么，因此不信任他。由于这部分属实，我同意了。”引用结束。这听起来很耳熟。这基本上和朱莉·陈40年后得到的反馈是一样的，即人们无法解读她的表情，观众无法与她产生共鸣。
The stereotype of the inscrutable Asian has a long history in Western countries. It paints people from Asian nations as perpetual foreigners who are just too different to assimilate. In Milar's article, he shows dramatic before and after pictures of the translator, and it's clear that he thought the work he was doing was more than just cosmetic. The caption, I can't remember the exact words, but he says something like, now he is frequently mistaken for Italian or Spanish. Milar goes on to say that the translator, his face totally transformed now in European
“深不可测的亚洲人”这一刻板印象在西方国家有着悠久的历史。它将亚洲国家的人民描绘成永远的外国人，他们太不同了，无法融入。在米拉德的文章中，他展示了这位翻译戏剧性的术前和术后照片，很明显，他认为自己所做的工作不仅仅是美容。标题，我不记得确切的词了，但他大概是说，现在他经常被误认为是意大利人或西班牙人。米拉德继续说，这位翻译，他的脸现在完全变成了欧洲人
looking, plans to go to the United States to study for the ministry. So I mean, this is where people get angry at Malar, not only, you know, whatever his ethics are in terms of the medical stuff, but the cultural assumptions where he thinks he can completely transform this man's life and his body through the act of surgery. Over the course of his year in South Korea, Malar continued performing bluffer aplastion others, specifically South Korean sex trade workers who were trying to appeal to American GI's. He described a woman's desire for eyelid surgery to be for economic reasons.
的样子，计划去美国学习神学。所以我的意思是，这就是人们对米拉德感到愤怒的地方，不仅是因为他在医疗方面的道德问题，还有他的文化假设，他认为自己可以通过手术完全改变这个人的生活和身体。在韩国的一年里，米拉德继续为其他人进行眼睑成形术，特别是那些试图吸引美国大兵的韩国性工作者。他将女性对眼睑手术的渴望描述为出于经济原因。
To Milar's Blufferoplasty offered a solution to a cultural disconnect between East and West. But it was only those with Asian features who were expected to change their bodies. With the population of East Asians growing in the United States, Mlard speculated that double eyelid surgery might be useful at home in the US, too. GIs were bringing home Japanese and Korean brides, and Mlard thought that plastic surgeons could help them integrate into American society. He definitely saw himself and liked to see himself as an advocate of the surgery. I don't think he could possibly, though, have anticipated how it would get picked up in different ways.
对米拉德来说，眼睑成形术为东西方之间的文化脱节提供了一个解决方案。但只有那些拥有亚洲特征的人才被期望改变他们的身体。随着东亚人在美国的人口增长，米拉德推测双眼皮手术在美国国内也可能有用。大兵们带回了日本和韩国的新娘，米拉德认为整形外科医生可以帮助她们融入美国社会。他确实把自己看作，也喜欢把自己看作是这项手术的倡导者。不过，我想他不可能预料到它会以不同的方式被采纳。
According to the American Society of Plastic Surgery, more than 12,000 Asian Americans had double eyelid surgery in 2017. The procedure has become completely normal for both women and men. And given the racist history behind the procedure, it makes sense that some people in the US are vocally critical about it. Who says, look, eyelid surgery is fake, it's anti-Asian, you're erasing ethnic markers. So it's not so much about necessarily just a droopy eye, it's also about wanting to look more Caucasian.
根据美国整形外科学会的数据，2017年有超过12,000名亚裔美国人接受了双眼皮手术。这项手术对男女来说都已经变得完全正常。考虑到这项手术背后的种族主义历史，一些人在美国对此持公开批评态度是有道理的。他们说，看，眼睑手术是虚假的，是反亚洲的，你是在抹去种族特征。所以这不一定只是关于下垂的眼睑，也关于想要看起来更像白人。
Chen's story has prompted a backlash. Some critics accused her of selling out. Others claimed she had other stuff. But not everybody buys this narrative of selling out. The Western media pretty much consistently has a pitting or condescending attitude about how Asians view plastic surgery. This is Uni Hong, a journalist and author of the Birth of Korean Cool. She says the reaction to Julie Chen's double eyelid surgery was a perfect example of this condescending attitude. People were accusing her of being ashamed of her race,
陈的故事引发了强烈反对。一些批评者指责她出卖了自己。其他人声称她还有其他东西。但并非所有人都买账这种“出卖”的说法。西方媒体在看待亚洲人如何看待整形手术时，几乎总是持有一种居高临下的态度。这是洪恩妮，记者兼《韩国酷的诞生》一书的作者。她说，对朱莉·陈双眼皮手术的反应就是这种居高临下态度的完美例子。人们指责她为自己的种族感到羞耻，
of being ashamed of having Asian eyes, and I was kind of gobsmacked by this, because again, a person's body should be their business. Haul and can speak from personal experience because she's had the surgery done herself. She says it was no big deal. The procedure doesn't take very long at all and might even be something like 20 minutes. Haul says that the stigma around double eyelid surgery is distinctly American. The American media tends to assume that Asians are getting plastic surgery to look Caucasian,
为拥有亚洲眼睛感到羞耻，我对此感到目瞪口呆，因为再说一次，一个人的身体应该是他们自己的事。洪可以从个人经验出发，因为她自己也做过这个手术。她说这没什么大不了的。手术过程一点也不长，甚至可能只需要20分钟左右。洪说，围绕双眼皮手术的污名是典型的美国现象。美国媒体倾向于认为亚洲人做整形手术是为了看起来像白人，
and in a multicultural society like the US, where racism is a daily reality, it could be hard for us not to interpret people's motivations through that lens. But Hong says the attitudes about plastic surgery are different in South Korea where blepharopl plastic was first popularized. While the procedure might have originated with the desire to look more Western, that isn't necessarily why South Korean people get it anymore. The history of double eyelid surgery might have been motivated in kind of racial hegemony or something like that, wanted to impose Western beauty standards on Asians,
而在像美国这样的多元文化社会中，种族主义是日常现实，我们很难不通过那个视角来解读人们的动机。但洪说，关于整形手术的态度在双眼皮手术最初流行的韩国是不同的。虽然这项手术可能起源于看起来更西化的愿望，但这不一定是韩国人现在做它的原因。双眼皮手术的历史可能受到某种种族霸权之类的动机驱动，想要将西方审美标准强加给亚洲人，
but as with a lot of things, including cuisine and art, it can have a certain origin, but it always gets adapt and then localized, and Koreans have completely taken the ball and run with it. The surgery has taken on a new meaning. Now we are really focused on making beauty, instead of making Western faces. This is so young Lee Im, a scholar of South Korean plastic surgery at Seoul National University.
但正如许多事物一样，包括美食和艺术，它可能有一个特定的起源，但它总是会被适应并本土化，而韩国人已经完全接过了这个球并跑了起来。手术有了新的含义。现在我们真正专注于创造美，而不是制造西方人的面孔。这是李素英，首尔国立大学韩国整形外科研究学者。
She says South Koreans aren't looking to have their eyes change for the same reasons they did back in the 1950s when Malar was around. Today, they're aspiring to their own uniquely South Korean standard of beauty, which has been shaped by complex cultural factors. In the late 1990s, South Korea suffered through a financial crisis and the International Monetary Fund, or IMF, stepped
她说，韩国人不再像米拉德时代那样为了同样的原因改变眼睛。今天，他们追求的是自己独特的韩国审美标准，这种标准是由复杂的文化因素塑造的。在20世纪90年代末，韩国经历了一场金融危机，国际货币基金组织（IMF）介入
in and completely restructured and modernized the economy. The country has since recovered and is now the 11th largest economy in the world, but the job market has become so competitive that getting a job can still be incredibly hard. People do whatever they can to compete. So your appearance is one of your resource. So you have to kind of develop your appearance to have a better job and better future or better partner. And the South Korean government has also fully embraced and encouraged the plastic surgery industry. There is governmental effort to promote Korean plastic surgery industry. There is governmental effort to promote Korean plastic surgery industry.
并彻底重组和现代化了经济。该国此后已经复苏，现在是世界第11大经济体，但就业市场变得如此竞争激烈，以至于找工作仍然极其困难。人们尽其所能去竞争。所以你的外表就是你的资源之一。所以你必须发展你的外表以获得更好的工作、更好的未来或更好的伴侣。韩国政府也完全拥抱并鼓励整形外科行业。政府有促进韩国整形外科行业的努力。
So, plastic surgery, as well as Korean culture, has been kind of a national income source for the Korean government. The South Korean government has lifted a ban on medical advertising and revised immigration rules to make it easier for foreign patients to get long-term medical visas. And now medical tourism makes up a huge portion of the plastic surgery industry. People come from all over the world to have worked on in South Korea. And of course, many South Koreans get plastic surgery too.
所以，整形手术以及韩国文化，已经成为韩国政府的一种国民收入来源。韩国政府取消了医疗广告禁令，并修改了移民规则，使外国患者更容易获得长期医疗签证。现在医疗旅游占了整形外科行业的很大一部分。人们从世界各地来到韩国进行手术。当然，许多韩国人也做整形手术。
Allied surgery is still the most popular procedure. It's so common that a lot of young people in South Korea will get the surgery as soon as they're old enough to. It's like a gift when you graduate high school. Before you go to the college, it's kind of a, it comes with a laptop, gift set. This is GEO, a photographer who spent time documenting the healing process of South Korean plastic surgery patients. She's witnessed many of the recent trends
眼睑手术仍然是最受欢迎的手术。它太普遍了，以至于韩国的许多年轻人在达到年龄后就会去做手术。这就像你高中毕业时的礼物。在你上大学之前，它就像笔记本电脑、礼品套装一样。这是GEO，一位花时间记录韩国整形手术患者康复过程的摄影师。她目睹了许多最近的趋势
in Korean beauty culture affecting both women and men. So basically, you have to have a chip somewhat baby-looking face, which is lighter skin, and very big eyes, narrow and high nose. And Yo says that many people also want a sharp narrow chin. The overall effect they go for isn't necessarily Caucasian. It's almost pixie-ish. You definitely have to have a very sharp V line chin
在影响男女的韩国美容文化中。所以基本上，你必须拥有一张有点像婴儿的脸，即更白的皮肤，非常大的眼睛，窄而高的鼻子。而Yo说，许多人也想要一个尖而窄的下巴。他们追求的整体效果不一定是白人。它几乎是精灵般的。你绝对必须拥有一个非常尖的V型下巴，
with no jaw line, with very straight narrow jaw lines. So they tend to cut out those bones. To achieve this complete look requires a lot more than double eyelid surgery, which is fairly easy and low risk. jaw reduction surgery is much more invasive and dangerous. Of course, any surgery has its risks, but this one involves slicing out a significant amount of jaw bone, and could lead to complications like nerve damage or chronic jaw pain. One in five South Korean women have gotten some form of plastic surgery done.
没有下颌线，有着非常笔直狭窄的下颌线。所以他们倾向于切掉那些骨头。要实现这种完整的造型，需要的不仅仅是双眼皮手术，后者相当简单且风险较低。下颌缩小手术要侵入性得多，也更危险。当然，任何手术都有风险，但这个手术涉及切除大量的下颌骨，并可能导致神经损伤或慢性下颌疼痛等并发症。五分之一的韩国女性做过某种形式的整形手术。
And if you look at women ages 19 to 29, that number shoots up to one in three. Yo says women face such immense cultural pressure to conform physically that it can be hard to resist. You should fight for your own beauty, you shouldn't follow the idealized beauty, you shouldn't be scrutinized by the culture, but it is so hard to fight and it is so much easier and peaceful to be part of the culture. But as critical as you feel about some aspects of the plastic surgery culture in South Korea, she does wish that the rest of the world would just stop being so judgey. Because whether you're a Korean woman trying to meet your culture's exacting beauty standards, or an Asian American woman like Julie Chen, weighing the choice between changing your appearance
如果你看19到29岁的女性，这个数字会飙升到三分之一。Yo说，女性面临着巨大的文化压力去在身体上顺从，以至于很难抗拒。你应该为自己的美而战，你不应该追随理想化的美，你不应该受到文化的审视，但战斗太难了，成为文化的一部分要容易和和平得多。但尽管Yo对韩国整形手术文化的某些方面感到批评，她确实希望世界其他地方停止如此评判。因为无论你是试图满足文化严苛审美标准的韩国女性，还是像朱莉·陈那样权衡改变外表选择的亚裔美国女性，
or hobbling your career prospects. You're basically damned if you do, damned if you don't. The art of making metal facial prosthetics for soldiers injured during World War I. After this. So we talked a little bit about how war accelerated the development of medical fields, like reconstructive and cosmetic surgery. It also drove the growth of prosthetics, a field at the intersection of medicine and art and design, and 99PI producer Vivian Lee is back to talk a little bit more about that field. Like with reconstructed surgery, the development of prosthetics really advanced during World War I, but specifically a branch of medicine called an aplastology, which deals with customized prosthetic pieces for people with missing
或者阻碍你的职业前景。你基本上是“做也难，不做也难”。为一战受伤士兵制作金属面部假体的艺术。之后。所以我们谈到了一点战争如何加速了医学领域的发展，比如重建和美容外科。它也推动了假体的发展，这是一个处于医学、艺术和设计交叉点的领域，99PI制作人薇薇安·李回来谈谈那个领域。像重建外科一样，假体的发展在一战期间确实取得了进步，但特别是一个叫做“面部修复学”（anaplastology）的医学分支，它处理为缺失的人提供定制假体件
or malformed parts of the body, especially for the face. World War I was a really rough time to be a soldier because technology like the machine gun and the tank had advanced to make killing people and injuring people so much more effective. Yeah, you hit the nail right on the head. And given the nature of trench warfare, soldiers would need to pop their heads out of these trenches
或身体畸形部位，特别是面部。一战对士兵来说是一个非常艰难的时期，因为机枪和坦克等技术的发展使得杀人和伤人变得更加有效。是的，你一针见血。考虑到堑壕战的性质，士兵们需要把头伸出这些战壕
to fire off rounds or to advance, making their faces vulnerable. So this made facial injuries really common, but it was also this moment in history where medical treatment was starting to get a lot better, which is good, but you also had men suffering from terrible head wounds and then surviving. So you have a lot of soldiers
来开火或推进，这使他们的脸部变得脆弱。所以这使得面部损伤非常普遍，但这也是历史上医疗开始变得好得多的时刻，这很好，但你也有士兵遭受可怕的头部创伤然后幸存下来。所以你有很多士兵
that are literally getting shot in the face, but they could now survive. It's really horrifying in and of itself, but it also made it hard for soldiers to come home and have a normal life with their new disfigurement. Exactly. And reconstructive surgery was still in the beginning stages, so you had things like skin grafts, but there really was nothing you could do in terms of plastic surgery for someone who had, you know, their jaw taken off or a gaping hole where their eye used to be. So anaplastology picked up in an aesthetic way where reconstructive surgery left off. And this is a really interesting intersection between art and medicine.
字面上是脸部中弹，但他们现在可以幸存。这本身就很可怕，但也使得士兵很难回家并带着新的毁容过上正常生活。没错。而且重建外科仍处于起步阶段，所以你有皮肤移植之类的东西，但对于那些下巴被炸掉或眼睛曾经所在的地方有一个大洞的人来说，整形外科真的无能为力。所以面部修复学在重建外科停止的地方以一种美学方式接手了。这是艺术和医学之间一个非常有趣的交叉点。
Right. So you need to be able to recreate a human face, which takes a lot of artistic talent, and that's where artists like Anna Coleman-Lad came in. She was an American sculptor who lived in Boston at the time. A lot of her pre-World War I artwork involved making like the bounding nymph and happy baby sculptures that you'd find in the mountains. And she founded something called the studio for portrait masks in France, which made facial masks for veterans with severe injuries to the face.
对。所以你需要能够重塑人脸，这需要大量的艺术天赋，这就是像安娜·科尔曼·拉德这样的艺术家介入的地方。她是一位当时住在波士顿的美国雕塑家。她一战前的大部分艺术作品涉及制作你在山上会发现的像“跳跃的仙女”和“快乐的婴儿”之类的雕塑。她在法国创立了一个名为“肖像面具工作室”的机构，为面部严重受伤的退伍军人制作面具。
So how did an artist from Boston go on to found this studio in France with this really lofty mission? She moved to France with her husband because he was a doctor with the American Red Cross. And while she was there, she read about this other sculptor in London who was making these facial pieces for veterans. So she got funding from the Red Cross to do something similar in France. That's so cool. So what type of work goes into making a mask like this? Each mask would take about a month to make. Lad would base each look off of pictures of veterans before their injuries to try to match as closely as possible with they looked like originally. And the process involved taking a plaster cast of their faces
那么一位来自波士顿的艺术家是如何带着这个非常崇高的使命在法国创立这个工作室的呢？她和丈夫搬到了法国，因为他是美国红十字会的医生。当她在那里时，她读到了伦敦另一位正在为退伍军人制作这些面部部件的雕塑家。所以她从红十字会获得了资金，在法国做类似的事情。太酷了。那么制作这样的面具需要什么样的工作呢？每个面具大约需要一个月的时间来制作。拉德会根据退伍军人受伤前的照片来确定每个造型，以尽可能匹配他们最初的样子。这个过程包括取他们脸部的石膏模型，
and then she'd shape the mask itself out of a thin sheet of galvanized copper. And these could weigh up to half a pound depending on how large the injury was. And they were held to the face, usually using string or wire. Sometimes they would use eyeglasses to keep them on if they wanted eye glasses.
然后她会用薄薄的镀锌铜片塑造面具本身。根据损伤的大小，这些面具的重量可达半磅。它们通常用绳子或金属丝固定在脸上。如果他们想要眼镜，有时他们会用眼镜来固定它们。
And so these things are made of metal. Yeah, copper. That's amazing. It seems like it takes a lot of creative interpretation to make the right type of mask at a metal. Right, yeah, and that's what made these specifically so special because she would have to hand paint each of the masks directly on their faces to make sure that their skin tones match. And matching the skin tone is especially tricky because when you're outside, the hue of
所以这些东西是金属做的。是的，铜。太神奇了。看起来用金属制作正确类型的面具需要大量的创造性诠释。对，是的，这就是为什么这些特别特别，因为她必须直接在他们的脸上手工绘制每个面具，以确保他们的肤色匹配。匹配肤色特别棘手，因为当你在外面时，你的肤色色调
your skin will change depending if you're in the sun or if you're in the shade. So she would basically need to split the difference between the two colors to make sure it wasn't extreme in either condition. And she'd also either use real human hair or slivered tinfoil to create the eyebrows or a mustache if they wanted it. And my favorite detail that she would do is, if the mask had to cover the mouth of the recipient, she would leave a gap in the lips just wide enough for a cigarette to be put in. I guess at that point, smoke up, just enjoy life. I'm not going to police your life at that point.
会根据你在阳光下还是在阴凉处而改变。所以她基本上需要在这两种颜色之间取一个折中点，以确保它在任何条件下都不会太极端。她还会使用真实的人类头发或银箔来制作眉毛或胡子（如果他们想要的话）。我最喜欢的细节是，如果面具必须覆盖接受者的嘴，她会在嘴唇上留一个缝隙，刚好够放进一根香烟。我想在那一点上，抽吧，享受生活。在那一点上我不会去监管你的生活。
So did they do anything? The mass they really were just cosmetic. Yeah, they're only cosmetic. They didn't have any functional purpose. You couldn't chew food or see again. But for someone who had already suffered a massive facial injury, they could really meet a lot. I'm sure at that, It's such interesting work.
所以他们做了什么吗？这些面具真的只是美容用的。是的，它们只是美容用的。它们没有任何功能性目的。你不能咀嚼食物或再次看见。但对于一个已经遭受严重面部损伤的人来说，它们真的意义重大。我肯定在那一点上，这是非常有趣的工作。
I mean, in the pictures, are really stunning. Yeah, and it's hard to describe these because when you think of a half-pound copper mask on someone's face, it probably doesn't sound like it's going to be very realistic, but there's this video of lad fitting these masks on veterans, and it's amazing how transformative they are once you see them in motion. And you can see for yourself on a video that we have up on the website it's at 99pi.org. Thanks, Viv. Thank you. 99% invisible was produced this week by Vivian Lee, mixed in tech production by Sheree Fusef,
我的意思是，照片确实令人惊叹。是的，很难描述这些，因为当你想到某人脸上半磅重的铜面具时，听起来可能不会很逼真，但有一段拉德为退伍军人安装这些面具的视频，当你看到它们运动时，它们是多么具有变革性，这太神奇了。你可以在我们网站上的视频中亲自看到，网址是99pi.org。谢谢，薇薇。谢谢。本周的《99%隐形》由薇薇安·李制作，技术制作由谢丽·福塞夫负责，
music by Sean Rihal. Katie Mingle is our senior producer. Kurt Colestead is the digital director. The rest of the team is senior editor Delaney Hall, Avery Trollfman, Joe Rosenberg, Emmett Fitzgerald, Terran Mazza, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KLW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. You can find them all at radiotopia.fm.
音乐由肖恩·里哈尔创作。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制作人。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队的其他成员是高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔、艾弗里·特罗尔夫曼、乔·罗森伯格、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、泰兰·马扎，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KLW的一个项目，在“广播街”制作。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。《99%隐形》是PRX旗下Radiotopia的骄傲成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立的集体。你可以在radiotopia.fm找到它们。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But you can get all the tools to decode the secrets of the built world. at 99pi.org you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并加入关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但你可以获得解码建筑世界秘密的所有工具。在99pi.org。你。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。